This work is pretty major from the point
of view that's not just putting in traffic signals.
It's also replacing and upgrading
sewer pipes, storm water pipes and water mains
So it's a pretty major piece of work.
We suggest commuters look at
alternative routes to avoid the intersection
because the more traffic that uses the intersection,
the more delays there'll be.
Some of those alternatives are
for people living on the west side of Rangiora
there's the Fernside / Flaxton / Townsend road link.
And that provides a direct
connection into the western side of Rangiora
For the east and north,
there's possibly using Rangiora-Woodend Road
as a route that will avoid Southbrook Road.
So they're the two main routes that
people should consider.
If people have use the intersection, then we'd suggest
they avoid the peak time and peak times are:
at school start and finish times.
And also from about four o'clock onwards
in the evenings, it gets pretty congested
So it's just avoiding those times if you can.